tired of using these Haram dating apps
and not getting nowhere with it that's
why we created uni students match first
ever matchmaking service for Muslim
Universal students and graduates sign up
now to find your spouse
Modi send it to meet me in Malaysia
he sent an emissary
can we remove the misunderstanding I
said what misunderstanding your police
and I know everything about me there's
no misunderstanding
no can we be friends I said no problem
as long as you don't tell me to do
anything against Quran Sunnah I don't
want your money you know what they
wanted me to do they wanted me to
support the government that what they're
doing in Kashmir is correct I said
nonsense
they gave me safe passage we will get
you back to India we will delete all
your cases
other what do you want nothing you want
then they're going and telling me can
you say what the Indian government is
doing is Kashmir is right I said oh my
dead body
in Kashmir you are persecuting a Muslim
Brothers how dare is totally wrong then
they wanted you to support the new Act
that is
citizen bill
that and today
unfortunately
this fanatic Hindu organization is
really troubling the Muslims of India
unfortunately all the Muslim countries
are silent it's a shame
it's a shame